y aquí tenemos el modelo molecular del
propano si observamos la molécula desde
esta perspectiva podemos ver la
proyección de newman en la conformación
alternada si rotamos el carbono frontal
que sería este carbono obtenemos la
conformación eclipsada la dejaré un poco
chueca para que puedan ver los enlaces
de atrás si la rotamos de nuevo
obtenemos la conformación alternada y si
seguimos rotando la molécula entonces
nos queda la conformación eclipsada que
la dejó un poco chueca para que puedan
ver los enlaces de atrás si rotamos
nuevamente nos queda la conformación
alternada y si volvemos a rotar
obtendremos la conformación eclipsado
pero si rotamos el carbono
otra vez regresamos a la conformación
alternada del propano
y aquí tenemos el diagrama de energía
para las conformaciones que vimos en el
vídeo por favor
vean el vídeo de análisis con formación
al del etano antes de ver este en el eje
y tenemos la energía potencial entre más
subamos más aumenta la energía entonces
empezamos con la conformación alternada
del propano y cuando rotamos el carbono
frontal 60 grados obtuvimos la
conformación eclipsada del propano
observen la diferencia de energía entre
estas conformación es la conformación
alternada tiene una energía potencial
baja y la conformación eclipsada tiene
una energía potencial alta recuerde a
menor energía potencial más estable es
la conformación así que la conformación
alternada es más estable que la eclipse
entonces necesitamos energía para pasar
de la conformación alternada a la
eclipsada y el ejemplo que use en el
otro vídeo fue una roca si tenemos una
roca y queremos empujarla hasta la cima
necesitaremos energía para lograrlo en
la cima la roca es menos estable
entonces a mayor energía potencial es
menos estable y a menor energía
potencial es más estable por lo tanto la
conformación alternada es más estable
que la eclipsada y cuando rotamos
nuevamente para pasar de ésta eclipsada
a esta alternada disminuye la energía
potencial pero cuando pasamos de la
alternada a la eclipsada aumenta la
energía y si pasamos a la alternada
disminuye la energía observen que hay un
patrón cuando pasamos de la
alternada a la eclipsada necesitamos
energía y cuando pasamos de la eclipsada
a la alternada disminuye la energía
todas nuestras con formaciones
eclipsadas tienen la misma energía
potencial y lo mismo ocurre con las
conformaciones alternadas entonces la
diferencia de energía entre la
conformación eclipsada y la alternada es
de 14 kilos urss por mol esa es la
diferencia
ahora que sabemos que hay una diferencia
de energía de 14 kilos urss por mol
entre la conformación alternada y la
conformación eclipsada del propano
dibujemos la proyección de newman para
cada una de estas con formaciones
empecemos con la conformación alternada
este carbono es el carbono frontal y se
representa con un punto ahora unido a
este carbono tenemos un grupo ch3
entonces tenemos un ch 3 y también
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia la derecha y
un hidrógeno hacia la izquierda entonces
otro hacia la izquierda
ahora sabemos que hay un carbono justo
atrás de este carbón pero sabemos que
estos hidrógenos de atrás están unidos a
ese carbón así que al carbono de atrás
lo representamos con un círculo en la
proyección de newman
este es nuestro carbono de atrás que
está unido a un nitrógeno hacia la
derecha también tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia la izquierda y finalmente tenemos
un hidrógeno hacia abajo
esta es la conformación alternada para
el propano ahora dibujemos la
conformación eclipsada parece un poco
más difícil pero empecemos con este
carbono que es el carbono frontal y lo
representamos con un punto después
tenemos el grupo ch3 hacia la derecha
ch 3 y después tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia abajo que lo voy a dibujar un
poquito chueco para que sea más fácil
poner los hidrógenos de atrás entonces
tenemos este hidrógeno hacia abajo y
después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia acá
que nos queda así
ahora vamos con el carbono de atrás no
podemos verlo porque nos tapa este
carbón pero sabemos que el carbono de
atrás está unido a tres hidrógenos este
este y este vamos a dibujarlos en
nuestra proyección de newman el carbono
de atrás se representa con un círculo
empecemos con este hidrógeno tenemos un
hidrógeno por aquí que es eclipsado con
el grupo metilo pero lo dibujamos un
poco separado para poder verlo ahora
dibujemos este hidrógeno tenemos un
hidrógeno hacia abajo y finalmente
hidrógeno por aquí ahora que ya tenemos
la proyección de newman para la
conformación alternada y la eclipsada
regresemos a los 14 kilos urss por mol
escribiré 14 kilos jules por mol en el
vídeo sobre con formaciones del etano
vimos que cada par de hidrógenos en la
conformación eclipsada tiene una energía
de 4 kilos por mol entonces este par de
hidrógenos eclipsados tiene una energía
de 4 kilos por mol lo mismo para este
par 4 kilos por mol así que podemos
predecir la energía del grupo metilo
eclipsado con este hidrógeno porque
sabemos que en total
debemos tener 14 entonces cuatro más
cuatro más lo que falta debe ser igual a
14 y claro la respuesta es 6
gilles x
entonces 644 nos da una tensión
torsional de 14 kilos urss por mol
ahora sabemos que la energía de un grupo
metilo eclipsado con un hidrógeno es de
6 kilos yúnes por mol